hello everyone and thank you for coming
to meanwhile in japan i know you have a
lot to do this year at GDC so appreciate
you taking the time to visit our session
my name is jeremy parish i'm the senior
editor at us gamer net and with me here
on the stage we have mark mcdonald of 84
limited and the man of the hour mr.
keiji inafune a of concept incorporated
and a few housekeeping notes before we
kick off if you're way off in Siberia
you might want to scoot in a little
closer so you can see what's on the
stage be sure to turn off all noise
making devices such as cell phones or
whatever else you might have them add
make make noise since it shows up on the
cameras in the cording for later and
finally this is a bilingual real-time
interpreted panel Kyoko here is going to
be providing interpretation for us so
please forgive you know any slight
awkwardness or pauses as we switch back
and forth between languages and with
that I believe we are ready to go all
right so let's start by talking to mr.
Inafune I hear about some comments he
made a couple of years ago at Game
Developers Conference where I believe he
said that Japan is over as your as your
opinion on Japan changed in the past
couple of years sir oh okie guac on 10 I
cannot do mundo sin la pagina Aramina
sturt Oh Mon Sep anaganaga soooo Capri
ah no cono America dystocia night Tito
guru Baron de moto Carnegie I not the
bottom us so you know to be completely
honest not in a big way I think those of
you guys in the audience here are aware
that our you know Japanese games are not
doing so well here especially in the US
but kind of overall so the energy level
still hasn't really come up yet
so overall yeah we still need to make a
huge amount of effort to get back to
where we used to be now you know in the
in the broader sense we still see a lot
of problems here in the US gaming
industry you know major studios closing
down layoffs there's there's a lot of
trouble around the world how would you
characterize the malaise that affects
Japanese games industry with with the
problems that we see here in the West
so stay on Oh yoga / e e mono game uno
sentosa socastee tato monday soo mi a de
ba ito nihon doctor go to Appa sekai de
noche noche o got a good to you karachi
Nocturna cannot even your huevos so I do
believe that there's still this thing of
Japan kind of either leading the way
leading something in our industry
whether it's a movement or basically
creating a path so I do feel that maybe
the effect that we're seeing in our
territory may have an effect later on
and the rest of the world I see so
speaking of sort of setting the way when
you left Capcom a few years ago and
became an independent developer you were
taking a step that actually isn't really
that common among established Japanese
game developers I was wondering if you
could talk about what it's like being an
independent developer in Japan and in
your perception how does that differ
from the indie experience that we have
here in the West
Sonia no mono warrensburg re-enact a
psyche nihon demo so the sea at oconee
Akutagawa des indes no stottah chicas go
game genie a game o mio Caro a casa
negara Scutaro to monday's quedo como so
no ichi in tow not a des named antonio
casino gaming tsukuri toka casino
untoten Oh Scott ah Toki no sono games
agree chica o Yaran de su vida varnas ko
ko ko' roga Kenzie Nina Turner kimochi
Atomos so even though I may have started
on kind of a negative note it's not all
negative and obviously me breaking out
and going independent and getting kind
of the influence or guess the effect
from seeing the indie movement out here
his sort of auroral helped me and
figuring out you know what it is that we
can do in the sense of how I feel just
in general about making games I feel
like obviously there's a lot of freedom
and I I like seeing and feeling like
we're making games and like we used to
do in the good old days so I feel that
my heart and soul is a lot more
healthier and a lot more freer that way
I think just to add to that like talking
about the the differences between
functioning as an Indian Japan and here
in the West like I think a lot of people
might not even realize here recently in
the West really how much things changed
gradually but if you look back over the
last seven years kind of the rise of
steam of xbla of all this digital
distribution and and how important
that's been for the rise of of the
Indies if you look back and realize that
Japan and a lot of ways is still
functioning in kind of a pre 2006-2007
level when when that kind of rose up and
without that landscape and that kind of
those methods of distribution like it
really really is challenging being in
indy
in Japan unless you're you know you
either end up working for a bigger
publisher or you end up working i think
a lot on cell phone games but you know
the mobile market is completed its own
thing as far as the console space that I
really realize the more than I'm out
there in the more that I talked to
Japanese Indies it's like well you know
if I make this game and I take this risk
who's going to play it and how are they
going to play it when you don't have a
big pc install base and you don't have
you know steam is there but it's not
what it is here and it's more difficult
to get on and I think that's a really
big difference between and that's
something that's going to be really
challenging as Japanese Indies kind of
try to come of age and maybe catch up
with the Western counterparts so um the
job sure I know Makka love you Tori
dinnae Antonio know nihon e ok route
taba indy no joke otivicon occupate-o
Roberto the snares Goku it's rice or
cuneo corrective a hidden snap rate
Stassi oh no oh na itachi kisame tanto
como chegar see the to buy in diesel de
ano gambit a doe coma di Maio me ricotta
no money Houma suit a prey occu- Roberto
yet oh you may owe me roo Tok Alaska
night you know Aaron des cadeaux demo
soredemo a perrito sakky mahima sudoku
no me no kagayaki tioga indian scooter
is to touch Anansi no me no cover get us
to that stone unlock owaranai sucheta no
school oh no Jimmy tenerte cootie otter
une des kuga quito neo no Indy so high
tech guru engine I gonna tivo new
Pokemon tarran Senay korekara 80 Indies
McConkey oh crap tycoons and i cannot
even Eva multimers so I completely agree
with mark and thanks for adding that you
know the environment that surrounds us
as Japanese independent developers is
quite different than what we have seen
in the Western market
so there's not as much of the user base
or the support or just the situation is
different even the structure of the
studio is quite different in Japan but
as I said earlier you know I'm full of
passion I'm also feeling the just a
genuine passion and just the shine and
the people's eyes of any developers in
Japan these days and the dream that we
we have for the future over here in the
West it seems like the indie community
is already starting to see those dreams
maybe come true it's much closer but you
know we're on the same path so we are
truly just having fun making games this
way and I hope that our movement in
Japan will change the path for indie
game development in the future in Japan
I spoke with a lot of indie developers
last year Tokyo Game Show and something
that a lot of people mentioned is that
the indie market there has been somewhat
you know it exists kind of in parallel
with the dojin market which is you know
the the fangame market where it's a it's
really about taking copyrighted concepts
and just iterating on those instead of
creating something original do you feel
that the the presence of the dojin
market over there has stunted the indie
market do you think that's something to
account for why we've only recently
heard about indie developers coming out
of Japan I think one one thing I think
is a little weird when I think about it
is Japan really has an early history
with indie development when I think
about how it lags behind now you know
you think back to even like PlayStation
1 with the net euros a which was a
basically consumers could buy a ps1
development kit which at the time was
kind of crazy and I guess the pc engine
even before that actually had something
similar that i just recently learned
about and then that you do have this
this dojin market which are for people
who don't know that's kind of like a not
only video games but it's basically a
word for like a click or group
for a club of anything like minded
people kind of do together as a hobby
you have a lot of comics a lot of
cartoons made by these kind of clubs and
they also make games and a lot of times
they are games that are based on like
somebody else's IP or they use this set
of characters that all the dojin people
have kind of decided to use there's like
a cast of 30 or 40 characters that have
all of these games I think it's in the
Guinness Book of World Records for the
most prolific game series ever there's
basically a couple come out every year
using these characters and in these
games but they've all kind of decided
that they do it as a hobby and that even
sometimes it's stated explicitly you
can't sell this stuff commercially and
there's almost I you know you you can
buy them at these big comic conventions
but it's and sometimes online and stuff
like that if you really search for it
but it's almost like an afterthought the
fact they sell them um and I guess yeah
it could be seen as something we're
probably a lot of people that's their
outlet for games and they don't think of
ever making games as a career but they
do it on the side as part of that club
but it could also be like a fertile
place where if there does become a kind
of distribution method in place maybe
some of those people will be like okay
maybe this time I won't use you know
whatever fist of the north star
characters are you know whoever in it
and I'll make the same game with my own
characters and actually try to make a go
of it oh no ma granny so no kotoba no
Tito stay in dt hanashi aesthetic 80
jitt sua 80 cop courney Nissan an
anemone cop courney high tataki knee cap
coma ah Cadogan West I de anoche dou
gamma Chi Minh heightening ento boku no
yoni oh no consumer on toast a ningun
tesco Gonzaga aikido a possibility
high-tech
Oh estatura a no tonari ni aru kara
Tabini OS camara de terre de saco de 80
arcade oh no you are yaku through Himiko
neatest famicon yokosuka Kali Oh Maisie
raritan de kado soraka day yeah y su
queda atras against [ __ ] yasaman
tenaga lucuma Megaman number so first of
all you know Mark was sort of helping
out with the definition maybe of you
know dojin vs indy and if I I want to go
back there too so the definition of
India and I'm going to have a kind of a
long intro to this but I joined cap on
27 years ago at that time Capcom's main
line of business was arcade game in
Japan its amusement the arcade team was
I had the luxury of being housed under
the mean headquarter building I was
assigned to the what we call the
consumer division which is for consoles
handhelds and whatnot so we were in the
side building and treated as such and so
the arcade game business was the main
and our job was to basically port
whatever was made for the arcade for the
famicom and and so forth and so but we
said you know what we're sort of tired
of just boarding our games and so we
want to launch a new title or new
project and the first one out of that
effort was actually megaman 0 toreano
homie quan chi moda Hajime original game
Oh scattante so immediate Oh industry in
this damn you doman chikara dogra to
stay there's no beer de haan toh AA
nomoto merit emulsion emoji bunt a
chikorita emirates kruti tajima Tonga
rockman megaman there so me they were so
you kimochi to know yep emoti taganga
epitome Asha cascoon right there oh no
memo Megaman Skinner stay right there so
you found out it a clear route to you
torrents Nagato Indies no tamashii tier
so it warned you on day amar koto body
1i eunuch us
not blowing us so again megaman was the
first original title that came out of
our team in those days and in a way if
we're talking about you know what's
Indian what's not or what's big-budget
mainstream and what's not for us I would
maybe say that that was our indie
movement because we were a not housed in
the headquarter main building and B we
weren't really doing what was asked by
us so we necessarily we weren't
necessarily sort of adhering to what was
requested for our team so you know if
you think about it it's really the
passion and the heart and soul that we
poured into that first original idea and
what became a product that is where I
think the heart of indie lies and
because of that were still sort of
connected those who are fans and still
follow Megaman from those days were
still connected in that way and so I'm
not particularly sort of concerned about
maybe the usage or how we label
ourselves I just feel that that for me
was an indie moment auto Roku noonday
Sun token a local in de hecho Megaman
scootin de kado so no Chino sanjeewa 80
she knew Shane Dawson I she got sandy
hey tay ninh Jenga no she got skaara
Megaman Todd's owaru tio quitate de
guitarra Oh Cassian dozing give the
carnage Yuta keiki Moana in Ganga suco
de caca wat tu kimochi tagaytay kokuboro
vue de monde cinnamony so no change in
dot asani whoa mr simon tomo mighty no
more energy minimus so to add to that
that team comprised of only the six of
us and of the sixth three of them were
new hires every year in Japan and April
company welcomes new hires so three of
them had really no
Arians and they didn't even know what
they were going to work on so if you
really think about it like Mark was
saying earlier with the dojin you know
this could be they have no experience or
maybe they're this is their creative
outlet there you know they want to
express what they want to make to those
three it could have been that okay I
don't know what I'm going to work on and
I have no experience but i SAT i have
the passion and I want to make games so
it feels very similar in that maybe that
was kind of a kind of a dozing like
feeling that they had and so fast
forward to today the three of those
members who joined us at that time
they're all now working on the mighty
number nine project with me one last
thing too about the dojin games I think
people would be surprised because people
haven't heard of them but when you go
and you see these games that are really
hard to find but you find some of them
are surprisingly good quality it was
almost just like I can't believe I
haven't heard of this because if it
looks this good you know I I must be
able to like search on the web and find
this is something like that and it's
just really like dark corners where you
will end up finding information and
people talking about it on that on the
internet because they are selling in
such small numbers but they're the
really is like incredible talent and you
know same with the indie games here you
see them just pouring in all this love
it's just a shame a lot of times because
you're like why do they have to you know
use those characters where they agreed
to never sell the game you know to make
this game because it's really you know
it's a game in the castle vania mold or
in the megaman mold or whatever but it's
a really great you know high quality
really well-crafted game a lot of times
yeah so
so speaking of mighty number nine the
kickstarter campaign for the game was
just maybe the second high-profile
japanese game development kickstarter
project ever how come we haven't hadn't
seen more Kickstarter's coming out of
Japan before now I know kick asada
camper hajimete AutoKey need a nose suey
yokai Jimmy O'Connor stony euro you are
a ton de kado hamburger I wanna know no
game yo con esto de more kick to start
our or shiranai toca kotoba da case
kakita Ottawa night so do you katana
dommatina esta mas are eaten terani whom
they were so no my Tina mother has
remember they were so game yoga Ezra
Kiku started tu mano shiranai what can I
do still okata girl hottie me when I
like pangaea multinational i see gimmoke
ago sir anand arup are soooo whole night
similar snow gusty tatiana joke a lot
but do not ask us so when we started the
campaign and even after omit one maybe
even after it ended from within our
industry in japan i received a lot of
comments emails and compliments even but
i would say that half of them i would
safely say that half of them didn't even
either know about Kickstarter or had
only heard the name or the label
Kickstarter so they didn't know what it
meant and so if the game industry in
Japan doesn't known that means that the
normal consumers and the citizens don't
really know it's really a small small
percentage of people who even knew
meaning if you don't even know that
exists obviously nothing's going to come
out of it so that was really where we
were at at that time I know it's not too
long ago but that was that was what was
happening in Japan yeah so so most
people might know this already but
Kickstarter doesn't exist in Japan
there's not a japanese version of
kickstarter it's just slowly branching
out to a few
countries now but it really when we were
doing the research for launching my
number nine you know we were looking at
trying to also engage like the Japanese
market because if we nice on has so many
fans on both sides of the ocean and you
know I think we found it was really
surprising how few people did know about
Kickstarter for something that we all
kind of take for granted again has just
come out of the last like five years but
I think we found a one kotaku Japan
article that had just been written a few
months before kind of like you know
walking somebody through okay you want
to get this Kickstarter thing here's
what the menus look like in English like
click here do this do that sort of thing
but you know even a hardcore gamer site
like like Kotaku Kotaku japan was kind
of just getting around to kind of
explaining it and talking about it in
general and so it was something during
the campaign to where I was like oh
people kind of aren't getting this
concept or don't you know you forget now
but if five years ago somebody would
have told me about Kickstarter it really
is kind of a radical idea when you first
hear about it and so it's still I think
my mighty number nine is really broken
it open in terms of people hearing about
it and reading it in mainstream
publications and stuff like that which i
think is great and I think in Japan
there's a big premium on okay well this
guy this well-known person is celebrity
this friend of mine or whoever has done
something so like I'm okay in trying it
and I think we're just now starting to
see that and I think going to see that
more in the coming months and years
people Japan really starting to
experiment with it an Ingo Tito Carano
comb buscas agony honea de fondos de
Soto system or Auto ketosis until can
cover / co' taughannock Roberto's go
scooter balconette timenado sister
maserati career- toca su you kutta
cheney not that gamma tsukumo the
congo google play sonu kannada a
pre-game otino-waa beaucoup de seara
pocketed automotive day yo tosin gamble
austere surra de oq mccarty naga game de
tomate el ejido napa-sonoma Navarre a
petrol station ID can I do so no se
quita naga epiny agua 800 sri guru day
o'connor burrito Co Co Co stays mad no
casi estoy como esta tominaga doe sous
la chata karate or Kiku started em okay
Moira esta muerto he cannot do so taking
a small step back just the concept or
the fundamental idea of funding is
slightly different in japan vs the West
funding is not looked at as something
that we would like to invest and call
that you know now we call it
crowdfunding but funding is more like
okay I need to borrow some funds and so
the the fundamental sort of
understanding and approach to what
funding is in terms of definition is
slightly different and with games you
know you need you need to invest in
games I think that games is a it's a
gamble for me and to win big you need to
invest and so I feel like these days or
the modern day Japan we don't
necessarily see funding as investment I
do feel that may be back in the days
that was a notion that people had but
hopefully through Kickstarter and other
crowdfunding initiatives that they will
start to believe that you know
crowdfunding is something that we can
investment invest in and get a return
whether that's a product or game or or
what have you so generally speaking how
did japan you know the the fans and
audience over there how did they respond
to mighty number 9 not just the
kickstarter but the game concept itself
Cesaro kicks tada they appear on
cosmetic people to enter Samina otro ET
kuru you are no not gonna strain tesoro
dorky tasuku motek return de kado so no
game oh cheta any test mo nobody on over
to crash karna game to you to corrode de
menos duster to test a good to go
tonight I stare at all worried to any
home the more at a positive when I can
query restore we cannot amo mas net
positive and I can come you can sink a
toxic a few what McCarthy was it so
insane phone thieves on crowd oh honey
buffoon to use tomo just awoke to the
snare already can't gain diameter and I
stole more sugoi oh no yono atascadero
what sort of negative in utilities to us
goodnight up do you count 0 re Mosley so
first of all I think that a lot of
people were surprised that we just
raised four million dollars through this
crowd funding initiative it came
probably as a surprise to a lot of just
users and fans and players on the game
side the game itself by sort of pushing
out and appealing the more classic
elements what we are trying to do with
mighty number 9 trying to bring in that
front and center probably worked
positively for those who are wanting
that kind of game so the expectations
are there not it so much negative
feedback or voices I hear it's either
they're really positive about it or some
are just kind of like you know oil maybe
that's not for me crowdfunding I don't
know what that is so you know I'll just
kind of take a seat back and watch what
happens I could say the the figures how
things ended up sussing out about it for
good I don't have the exact figures but
somewhere between ten and fifteen
percent of the backing came from Japan
which we took which might sound small
but we took as a success for something
where you know as a new concept to
people how you you know
get your amazon payment thing going or
you have to you know donate via paypal
or those sorts of things the concept of
tears and rewards and stretch goals and
all those kinds of things and also just
getting our updates happening in English
and Japanese and stuff you know it was a
really big challenge I think we learned
a lot through doing it but you know we
took that as like a big success they're
definitely less vocal than the Western
audience they've them for better and for
worse you know very really super polite
and very much you know they were there
and kind of watching but they are from
my perspective handling the community
stuff were more content to kind of sit
back and watch rather than like actively
participate or even you know volunteer
like hey what about this we want this
you know I felt like maybe they didn't
even know that it was their place to
enter into it and say like hey what
about a playable you know level with
female character or stuff like that
where I think the western people are
more used to Kickstarter having it be
participatory and actually like engaging
in it so that's something that's carried
through now to to the message boards
where they're like less active on the
Japanese side and stuff like that but
that's something like we're you know
working on doing getting people more
involved and engaged in Japan so what
other challenges did you experience in
running such an international campaign
Japanese developers a Western funding
source trying to appeal to people on
both sides of the ocean um i would say
on our side there was a lot of I guess
be communication like in a word I think
it a Kickstarter of that size and
complexity it's almost it mean it's a
project in and of itself and so running
that even all in the same language I
think would be challenging and being
able to respond to things quickly and
filtering back feedback to the
developers themselves and making sure
that
that when the developers are showing
things that are not complete and stuff
that that you know they're at we cover
their butts as well on that kind of
stuff and uh but much less when you add
in jet not only the Japanese language
but then you know there's a different
culture like so I I think the reason
part from again from like the 84
perspective part of the reason it worked
so well is you had me and and John who's
another one of the partners at a for who
are just huge you know Inafune a fans
huge fans of his old games and this was
just like a dream come true we didn't
have to imagine what people wanted it
was just like here's what we know people
are going to want because this is what
we front and then we also had Hiroko
who's the other partner at a 4 and we
had Nick you who's right over there the
producer and we had been Judd and these
are guys who are not just bilingual but
I think the thing that I really noticed
about this project was this sounds like
a big [ __ ] line but like they're
bicultural people and so a lot of times
you know when we would have these really
long drag out meetings about you know
what we should have a stretch goals or
what the language should be or stuff
like that we were understanding the
words that each side was saying but it
was more a matter of well they're coming
at it more from this perspective and it
really was more like a cultural thing
and you know Hiroko did a lot to you
know it would almost be like within just
within 84 we were figuring the stuff the
two sides of it out because she could so
well represent kind of what the the more
Japanese way of thinking was and it's
not one side is better or worse it's
just that it's different and you know
even having lived in Japan seven years
and studied it and stuff like that and
being pretty familiar with game industry
and development and stuff like that
that's there's still a gap there and
that I think helped bridge that but it
was a lot of long hours and it was a lot
of you know keeping on the communication
thing like just being awake at the time
when people are awake in america was
something
with the time difference so you know a
lot of like waking up at 3am to to talk
to people and then things will get quiet
in the late afternoon so like going to
bed you know or early for that and
planning around that sort of thing but I
think that was the hardest thing but i
think it was also the thing that we
probably ended up like really doing the
best and succeeding at Serrano kick
estaba no campaign is on Castillo so das
koo koo roo yep I knew own demo cara de
maquillaje para oh no my tia takara
santo guinea yep a connoisseur kicked
o-tar 1000 Tokiko certain nice ankus
teddy bear opava person game otsuka
johannes cocina inner corner emotional
game Congress 80 enemy cetera in
ocotillo demo kung kaya paid mighty
noche de Chivo okie cotton wausau no
naka de tous en and Aikido so no naka
mimi ni boo boo no sono back end or
google no soporto Tito mahajan arancini
Sukhoi khatta meetha tu no God otter
suku suku yo sista google definite yes
so ever since our campaign started and
ended i have received either messages or
emails from industry insiders you know
similar to my situation saying you know
what we've seen the success of mighty
number nine and we have an idea what do
you think and then come to me and ask
about it but they really only talk about
the game and that's not a bad thing
because the game still you know the
concept still needs to be great in order
to kick off a hopefully a successful
campaign but I think what they are
probably not thinking enough about is
really the logistics and the backend
support and with our situation with
minded number nine you know 84 leading
the the the initiative in that sense we
didn't take it lightly we in fact that
was one of our key sort of ingredients
and really a big role that they played
too
put this together and to keep it
together so of course the core which is
the game and the concept needs to be
appealing to the people but behind the
scenes there's so much going on and we
made sure that that all work to the a no
sew mama karma cikita quedo hot scenario
Inga any mods it's were so your
communication to the men but the Utah
corroded is named by supporters to
Maroni until to call a day at oneish RI
are no koe haga a ton they saw no homo
goodnight a mom s it's a naked oh boy oh
aqui conmigo no kana do you go to get
Akira no cannot you know kohana she
stands sundo Guinea daremo Kiko stop
erotic overnight there you don't start
or I'm I sake you are star chick USADA
seiko sakutari masti o2 guru guru toe
toe toe adidas room Megiddo Serena nine
Jota no naka de na [ __ ] committing a
tecate to Margo massari mauritanie
swoopo nettle you are in a horizontal
Rita toca Cano project aratai sigamos
risotto tenaga expand tsukitachi vicino
unit and a name otro integrate immunity
Dora Cano mighty no chi minh eva oratory
tight unit Rene stone in a cup and a the
superior scattered so to add to that
when the idea came together about
Kickstarter and launching this campaign
besides 84 there may be about two other
candidates that we wanted you know them
to play this role that April ended up
playing and we sort of went to this
interview process and you know wanted to
know what capacity what they were
capable of and you know how they were
going to contribute but all the all
these groups no one had any Kickstarter
experience so no one had a head start no
one had a handicap so they were all
lined up you know straight on on the
start line and what was really the key
was that it was purely the passion and I
think the desire to
to work with enough Anna or myself and I
felt it the strongest coming from then
and they just felt they also said that
you know it just sounds like a great fun
project and we want to be involved so 84
came on board that way and the same goes
to integrates the guys who are
developing the game with me so no one
person on the mighty number 19 right now
i should say the other way everyone on
the mighty number 19 wanted to work with
me or on this concept on this idea that
i wanted to put out so that's how the
team came together so before we talk any
more about the game i know you had some
new footage that you wanted to show I
don't know if you'd like to introduce
that before we roll it yo Co Co Nieto
yummy nummy said I not the video chota
mota kaise na oppa my Dino doma detect a
note you know satoko Misurata raccoon o
GD GD karate go to the mo tech demos so
I did bring a short video clip I wanted
to show where we're at the latest on
mighty number nine so let's go and take
a look
hiya know each a no game ogham nto
katachi divas encaje a no-go group
origami ah mrs. tante's creamy Serena
cotton desperto missio cannot hijo de
hecho yo on Madison damask adore 80
career kagaz ooga Romero monde des neige
Yamamoto so sunday a kite Parramatta
terrace appeared over me reading the
Tarot Simon is tina's so this is the
first time action showing actual in-game
footage because I know at the very
beginning you saw me playing it and I've
put out some videos of just me playing
it with a camera showing that but this
was taken this is from a bill may be
from about a month ago so we've already
made progress since then and hopefully
we can show you more in the future so on
the development of my new number 9 how
has it been different than you know the
usual development cycle to have to
support and interact with the community
all during the process
saucony on o'kiku stata the souk sorry
no esta la chica remote chica taisetsu
to go to the Hutchinson to she needs me
on Reata murata you know to manage it is
near to con game cajas de Navarre / e
sono community a toy nebach are so
touchy universidade de carga en Austin
Sakura mochi not a snake on games
society career route to canoga no 40 oh
I get a credit to you taco day after day
ahem te arawa on Tony so I skied a qu na
cikini moti Raju contesta quedo solo
society moreover too touchy 29 nani maka
what is net on vaca resto de Janerio
kittymuz so as i said earlier you know
eight for being one of the team's behind
the scenes that have been supporting
this huge effort the community the
backers themselves are they are another
very very important layer of support for
us without their support this would be
possible and then because of their
support it sort of raises the quality
almost automatically of the game for us
because we know that we have people that
are waiting for this and so yes we're
responsible we're in charge of making
the game but I don't think that's the
difficult part that you know I don't see
that as as being that hard it's more of
wanting to gain if the feedback and then
try to respond to that or roof like that
somehow into the product that we're
making I think something that's pretty
cool to see like from from our
perspective is so you know during the
Kickstarter campaign there was I don't
think it was reluctance but it was there
was unfamiliarity with okay well what
what's okay to show people and not okay
to show people and is it really okay if
we're showing people stuff that's not
really you know done or polished like is
that respectful to the to the final
player and also you know if we know
sounds like led the way with with some
early with some earlier experiments and
trying to involve the fans in the game
but at the same time there was a okay we
have to be really careful about what we
promised fans and so you know at the
beginning it felt like we were pushing
more for that kind of that kind of thing
and they were a little more careful
about it but actually now I think it's
really cool to see so like it for
example at the end of that video you
know there's like an inside joke to the
to the backers from something that one
of the Packers made of one of the bosses
joking saying you know they were teasing
that it was a red boss and they drew
like this at transforming apple guy and
so that as the guy who chops the card up
at the end but it's now to the point
where I'm surprised you know they're
beyond what I what were even suggesting
in terms of engaging the community will
be talking and having a meeting and
somebody will bring up something on the
message boards that I haven't seen you
know they'll will be doing screenshots
and stuff like that they hired a
community manager Dina who's doing an
awesome job just really giving this
constant flow of updates it's now the
challenge for me actually he is keeping
up with all the stuff they want to do
you know stuff like showing another
little movie here at GDC there was
something that they showed at dice like
they've really embraced the entire model
and spirit beyond you know what I think
we even hoped all on their own I think
that's been been like a really cool
thing to see throughout development and
I know there's a lot more bigger things
coming up that we have to do like the
design of boss contest and like a lot of
the cool stuff at the Kickstarter is yet
to come but you know that just gives me
more and more confidence that it's going
to go off great seeing that kind of
stuff so traditionally download only
content games have not been nearly as
successful in Japan as they are here in
the West how are you planning to deal
with that hurdle once-mighty number nine
actually makes it out
Soriano mighty wats Lenny Monica Bay
guru teacher Cody afternoon they're
determined Akiko start out the new homes
in iron a tu jana kabhi cara the
community out Scotty no games greet you
no mo Jeremy our initiative Oh tonight
kaboom Oh noriko a 16-day Cubano nah
know da Hye Jin tu como con tanto a nice
kaduna require a route to come yep re
download on Rosati no appetite a tease
me download hushing de vocht atticus a
casa luca toni optare penny oh no Indies
go genki natashka and a persona too many
more demanding sa kusina kk nighty koto
desu nee so you see miramonte oh no no
no download oh but me jinko reacted
somebody test so mighty number nine the
theme is all about breaking down the
walls so first this was you know one of
the first out of Japanese developer
doing a kit successful Kickstarter
campaign so that's the first wall we
broke down second the community being
with us and creating game that's not
done in Japan so that's another first a
wall that we broke down so understanding
that you know digital distribution
downloadable game and the business self
is not some it's not an easy wall for us
to break that's for sure but i think my
communicating and sort of selling the
pros what what is great about
downloadable content what is great about
digital distribution kind of selling
that idea and having them understand the
ease of it that the the you know
simplicity of it is probably something
that we can do so by doing that
hopefully we can break that wall and if
we succeed we feel that we can open up a
new path for our fellow indie developers
so that would be our mission ok so one
last question before we open the floor
to QA this is a bigger one what what
trends do you see happening in the near
future in Japan in in all aspects of
gaming
well so well as we've been talking about
i think an obvious one is crowdfunding i
think we've heard at 84 and influence on
mentioned hearing from a lot of other
japanese creators some of them not known
but some of them pretty well known about
interest in crowdfunding and and sort of
what we were able to do what we were
able to do with my new number nine so i
think and i hope you're going to see
more things like that and as we've been
kind of alluding to indie scene is kind
of burgeoning but it's there and it's
getting help you know recently there was
a bits of the second bit summit japanese
indie show just right before GDC if you
guys don't aren't familiar with it you
should google it and check it out really
cool thing it's growing I was like ten
times the show this year that's
something that that James milky and has
been really pushing and a lot of us have
kind of gotten behind it and that is
starting to get a real that community
feeling that Indies have here where
they're helping each other out and
sharing resources and knowledge and and
that's going to be completely necessary
going forward for them to rise but I
think you're going to start to see here
about more games coming out of Japan
hopefully getting on stuff like steam
those games being more polished and
stuff like that you know the indie games
now here are pretty damn sophisticated
even compared to like three or four
years ago so it's still early days I
think speaking generally about Japan but
I think you're going to hear more and
more that and yeah hopefully just the
trend towards more people becoming
independent you know Coach igarashi just
recently left Konami just this week that
that news came out and so I think a lot
of people are going to be watching
mighty number nine a lot of people are
going to be watching igarashi and sort
of dependent on the success of those
hopefully we're going to see more of
both of those kinds of things so now
know the only knows a ton and ro their
mocha can go nose to the snare hey Tony
unguent a Jew goonie 800 kinetic artist
nishikant Oh kuwata error at a company
so touchy tonight she's a nasty mikuni
dashiki Monica Jin's I'm Oh [ __ ]
irritated tu naka de que usted second
itachi makati GDIT nova a ton Desna
takara singing our hookah gamba renova
geez a new homes in the des neige come
on over us too touchy new account IRA
negeriku whose resto touches sir ganga
toe in d0 missoni sukhani our vaca de
indias resto tottori she came on I she G
kamenashi mo sorry amo solo tonight CTU
naka de da gamba thika tu carrito soul
hora and onions in a gamble back to
corona Kieran's negara quito coke rascal
Martika night omens oh so you know NE ho
no hero day at our toka segun oni ho no
se que él dice rugae moi co no chiisana
akari toka chiisana to crocker a
schematic or 80 motoren de quito indies
god nanticoke IT guru tonight ask a lot
of my boss so um i'm going to i let me
think about you know what are the
qualities of us of us japanese people we
are not very good at or we don't have a
tendency to be good at being provided
are being presented with a certain
amount of money and plenty of resources
and you know having that luxury and then
saying ok projects start and delivering
at the end we are a very small island
country which means we
only have you know what we have aren't
sitting and living in our Island so
limited resources limited people and if
you really go away back in time to our
you know older generations they made
things work by really being creative and
by doing that Japan you know succeeded
in representing their country in various
industries around the world in the past
so I feel like that situation is very
similar to where us Indies are situated
today in Japan we actually may work
better when we are restricted and have
limitations and have certain boundaries
to work with because when that situation
is sitting in front of us we get very
very creative and so I feel like maybe
the indie communi Indies situation the
environment that we are and today will
actually push us to become a lot more
creative and maybe that from there we
will have the next you know Japanese
parenthesis video game here or even a
Japanese here or a Japanese video game
or a game that's going to represent
Japan in the global market so I feel
like there is a small sort of light that
will grow into something a lot more
bigger in the future and you know
hopefully that's that's happening
already right now and that we can help
to push that forward all right well we
have about five minutes left so that's
time for maybe two or three questions so
if you want to line up at the
microphones and take a shot um hi this
question is for you know food ice on in
regards to what you speak of community
involvement with mighty number nine I
see a lot of parallels with what went on
during the development of mega man
legends three and unfortunately we all
know how that turned out so I'm
wondering if you're taking any of the
lessons perhaps learn during that and
maybe did did the failure of that
particular project influence your
decisions say with what you share with
backers and whatnot so the question was
what lessons have been taken away from
mega man legends three that project with
the community for mighty number nine I
want to say one thing that I think
infinity son learned is he entered in
both of the Bothan mega man legends
three and in mighty number nine there
was a contest among different artists to
draw to draw their version of it and in
both cases he lost and with mighty
number 9 he learned to directly tell the
fans like oh isn't it so terrible I lost
if only the fans would draw a bunch of
versions of my character so of course
the fans responded and have kind of kept
that idea live so I think that was that
was probably if one listen I know DJ's
oh no toki no community gasp i stopped
de Vaca John I in de so criminality or
Eva re o 8.o hon tony re Takata son
origins rotor kinoko meteo suzuki root
EVO katachi de amalah opera community no
a ricotta ricotta Arroyo MonaVie negara
Sundiata so of course I don't see the
the outcome of Legends three I don't see
that as you know a failure per se we
learned a lot and I think for me it's
that because we learned so much during
that time we are able to sort of reflect
anything that we learn from that into
our current campaign so it's still just
an ongoing process for me all right and
we have time for one more question so
make it good ok hopefully it's good so I
was mentioned that Coach igarashi who's
the steward of castlevania Akamai Joe
Dracula has left Konami to go indie and
in the interviews that come out in the
last few days he specifically mentioned
you you know Funes on and mighty number
nine as inspiring him to go forward and
to be able to go on that path and I was
just wondering or I'd like to hear sort
of mr. una Funes reaction to possibly
the possibility of
his project and him leading the way like
sort of like a new revolution for
well-known Japanese game creators to
give fans what they want so just like
this sort of here like a reaction or
something from his side since uh since
eegah had given him a shout out and
those interviews okay so the question is
what is mr. in oakland a's response to
kochi igarashi citing him as an
influence in parting konami yes
so the mother ah no arrests are no you
can he score 80 computer gosh Missoni mo
mono secured okara mì-runach too touchy
nico nico yo text emirate they're known
as Amanda Scotty tamarod you khoto in
des cadeaux to connect or ocupa anixter
to geneva who could wear again asked you
to vote yo [ __ ] a notochord a ba Walter
know in a horn a song writer car game
creatinine re master gambit Emma's
bugatchi stone re must atoka yo pro
megaman a gozar de artes no message my
status to asuka coke Tess oreo
cheesecake riddles desolate a skosh demo
son Austin agency a coat ariana.sea go
to go dictate induct in hua hsu risiko
do this then you never knock on a kazoo
you hurts again mistake when I desde you
tow so you Eco Boost at oh no Tina anoka
na tu gramo tansy I girls are hot saki
kitto zucchini ananka neons anymore toto
ECOWAS scott or Adeste na Christina
epicycles us Tony Napa each tier ii mii
toca jovanka game create another Amita
Hyneman whoa a prick yo guys mi rutina
sugoi re gotta in de ano sugimoto [ __ ]
Emma boku Nico sorry Ted gambit resto de
Chivo date se kasam se SI quieres animos
de cocina to mema's disabato de que lo
de arriba y además saputo's mas so first
of all I I applaud on eager hasta son
for his courage and commitment you know
for his future and you know whenever I
travel outside of Japan especially in
North America but just outside of Japan
in general
even coming to the CDC venue a lot of
people come up to me and and you know
say oh hello enough in a sign or I'm a
fan or I was influenced now I'm artist I
was inspired by your work etc etc and
you know not only does that make me
happy but if I had any effect if I had
any influence and anyone's life in any
way I am so grateful for that that means
that you know there's I have a purpose
in this life and and in my career and
what i'm doing and what i'm putting out
there in Japan it's sort of quite the
opposite not too many people come up to
me or they don't verbalize it they don't
express that in front of me and you know
want to come and shake my hand so I am
to hear that you got our son mention my
name and the mighty number nine campaign
I'm just so grateful and I wished him
the best of luck for his future and if
you anyone here or any of my fans are
influenced by anything that I put out or
I've said or you know anything then I
truly want everyone to succeed and I
support you and you know your decision
in whatever that is alright well thank
you very much mr. Inafune a mark Kyoko
thank you everyone for coming that's our
time so be sure to fill out your your
speaker evaluation and tell them how
amazing we all are it's very important
thank you
you